[Musica]
scegliere creatività quindi decision
making creatività libertà e
apprendimento Sono questi i miei quattro
punti di cui vorrei parlarvi stasera
quattro punti che in realtà
riguarderebbero quattro richiederebbero
quattro corsi condensati tutto in un uno
quindi per aiutarmi e anche aiutarvi voi
a seguirmi ho pensato di mettere questa
immagine che in realtà non è un'immagine
ma un insieme di immagini che vogliono
essere degli stimoli degli stimoli che
magari al momento vi diranno poco ma che
poi all'interno del del discorso
all'interno del di quello che andrò a
dire vi vi salteranno fuori e in qualche
modo vi spiegheranno vi aiuteranno a
capire quello che sto dicendo o vi
aiuteranno a dare un senso vostro a
quello che sto dicendo potrebbe capitare
direttamente durante questo contributo
ma magari anche questa sera quando
Andrate a casa oppure durante il vostro
sonno magari nei prossimi giorni vedrete
che prima o poi qualcuna di queste
immagine vi dirà e comunicherà con voi
allora iniziamo a parlare di decisione
quando parliamo di decisione io mi
occupo di psicologia e quando parliamo
di decisioni andiamo a capire come
L'uomo prende delle decisioni e se
queste decisioni sono razionali o
irrazionali Che cosa significa
razionalità ovviamente è qualcosa di
molto complesso che apre un tema che
richiederebbe molto tempo ma per noi
decisione razionale razionalità Scusate
è semplicemente la capacità di
utilizzare le risorse che abbiamo a
disposizione che sono distribuite
attorno a noi risorse di tipo
informativo di tipo sociale e cognitivo
per raggiungere degli obiettivi quindi
una volta che abbiamo degli obiettivi e
una volta che abbiamo i mezzi e le
risorse per raggiungere questi obiettivi
Ecco che siamo nelle condizioni di
prendere decisioni razionali lo
facciamo dipende perché non è così
semplice prendere decisioni studiare le
decisioni ma anche prenderle è veramente
un campo molto complesso perché prendere
una decisione razionale significa non
solamente valutare quello che io voglio
non significa solamente pensare quello
che mi farebbe piacere avere ma
significa anche proiettarsi in un futuro
e immaginarmi che in quel futuro quello
che farò adesso avrà un effetto positivo
che in qualche modo per me sarà
piacevole Questo è un compito cognitivo
di eccezionale complessità Ecco perché
ci dice Herbert Simon uno dei Padri
delle Scienze cognitive ma anche
dell'intelligenza artificiale ci dice
noi come uomini non abbiamo non am non
perseguiamo nemmeno la razionalità
cosiddetta illimitata ma abbiamo siamo
dotati e sfruttiamo una razionalità
cosiddetta limitata limitata Da che cosa
limitata
da dall'incontro dalla difficoltà
dell'incontro tra il nostro sistema di
calcolo cioè il nostro cervello la
nostra mente e il mondo che ci sta
attorno che è un mondo complesso è un
mondo incerto perché il futuro Non può
essere predetto può essere in qualche
modo stimato ma non può essere riportato
ad una situazione di sicurezza di
certezza Ecco che allora l'uomo
attraverso la propria razionalità
limitata riesce a prendere decisioni
Cioè a svolgere compiti assolutamente
complessi in un modo rapido veloce
quindi cosa prendo Prendo il pistacchio
perché non lo so ma so che lo voglio
prendere è un mio Capriccio direbbe
dostojevski non è tanto importante
calcolare l'utilità attesa delle mie
delle mie decisioni è importante seguire
il mio Capriccio perché è quello che mi
fa alzare la mattina non il calcolo
dell'utilità rispetto a quanto sarò
felice la sera ma semplicemente Il
Capriccio che mi porta a rimanere in
casa oppure uscire la razionalità
limitata quindi è uno strumento di cui
la l'evoluzione la nostra storia
evolutiva ci ha dotato per prendere
decisioni per fare per arrivare a
svolgere operazioni complesse in un modo
assolutamente naturale fluido e veloce
però ci dice Herbert Simon dobbiamo
anche essere consapevoli di una cosa che
l'uomo quando prende le proprie
decisioni e quindi secondo questa
razionalità limitata che ci porta ad
accontentarci della prima decisione
della prima scelta che è considerata
sufficientemente buona Ecco in questo in
questo suo operare l'uomo si mostra
stupido ignorante e passionale
e non solo l'uomo ovviamente anche la
donna stupido perché perché abbiamo
competenze con abbiamo una potenza di
calcolo che è limitata attenzione
limitata Working Memory limitata memoria
a lungo termine limitato e abbiamo di
solito svolgiamo i nostri compiti in un
tempo limitato quindi per poter fare
tutte queste
cose dobbiamo prendere delle scorciatoie
altrimenti appunto cadiamo in questa che
è la la la stupidità Cioè ci mostriamo
lenti Ed in effetti siamo lenti se
Confrontati con altri sistemi di calcolo
siamo ignoranti perché perché ignoriamo
la maggior parte delle informazioni lo
facciamo in modo sistematico Nel senso
che ci concentriamo solo su alcune delle
informazioni per arrivare in modo subito
alle decisioni tutta quindi vuol dire
che filtriamo le informazioni Tuttavia
la maggior parte delle volte siamo anche
ignoranti sul fatto di essere ignoranti
cioè ignoriamo il fatto che stiamo
ignorando la maggior parte delle
informazioni forse proprio quelle che Ci
servirebbero per prendere le decisioni
migliori quindi siamo spesso ignoranti
al quadrato e poi siamo passionali
perché Perché il nostro cervello
funziona in questo modo le emozioni non
sono separate dalla cognizione
quest'idea del di trovare il cervello
emotivo di isolarlo di corto circuit
Carlo per renderci esseri superiori In
realtà è un'idea che non ha senso Perché
il cervello funziona in modo
intrinseco emozioni e cognizioni
funzionano all'unisono perché Perché le
emozioni sono in primo luogo un sistema
basico primitivo di elaborazione dei
dati ovviamente ogni ione ha un suo
versante cognitivo vegetativo diciamo
fisiologico e
ehm comportamentale ma quello che ci
interessa qui l'aspetto cognitivo le
emozioni ci permettono di concentrarci
solo su una quota dello spazio che
contiene informazioni rilevanti come lo
sappiamo non lo sappiamo ma la nostra
diciamo così i nostri centri emotivi se
vogliamo la nostra amigdala sa già
elabora in modo molto veloce pochissime
informazioni e con questa è in grado di
modulare di guidarci Quindi anche le
emozioni sono un fondamentale strumento
di cui l'evoluzione ci ha dotato per
prendere delle decisioni arriviamo
quindi a definire due modi di prendere
decisioni un un in base a due a due
sistemi di pensiero che in modo molto
originale sono stati chiamati non da me
ma da altri molto più importanti di me
sistema 1 e sistema 2 in particolar modo
Forse conoscete Daniel keman Ecco il
sistema un è un sistema decisionale
veloce rapido
intuitivo analogico io dico anche fasico
perché agisce in modalità click and Run
appena vede lo stimolo parte e vi dà
subito la soluzione il sistema 2 invece
è un sistema lento canem Man dice pigro
È un sistema in qualche modo riflessivo
è un sistema tonico quindi che ha un
andamento tutto sommato lento e che ha
anche variazioni lente e che richiede
l'intervento della coscienza e voi
sapete che ogni qualvolta interviene la
coscien scienza nella nostra vita che è
essendo un sistema di integrazione dei
dati di secondo livello richiede tempo
Quindi state pur sicuri che di fronte ad
uno stimolo il vostro sistema 1 Vi avrà
dato già la risposta prima che il
sistema 2 si sia messo in moto sistema 1
e sistema 2 tuttavia tutto sommato non
sono in contrapposizione ma possono
lavorare in sinergia cioè riescono in
qualche modo a collaborare perché il
sistema un non è fallibile cioè non è la
sede della fallibilità come non lo è il
sistema 2 il sistema 1 è un sistema che
viene addestrato giorno dopo giorno è
qualcosa che impariamo a utilizzare nel
modo migliore ed ecco perché il grande
l'esperto di un certo dominio tecnico
usa soprattutto il sistema Uno cioè usa
le Mind Lines piuttosto che le
guidelines perché le ha fatte proprie e
ha sviluppato degli algoritmi cognitivi
che danno la risposta e danno una
risposta che è corretta dando una
risposta che è affidabile almeno
all'interno di un certo contesto Il
sistema 2 invece è un sistema che può
bloccare il sistema 1 può addestrare il
sistema 1 e può anche fare intervenire
il sistema di riflessione e dove sta gli
errori commettiamo più errori col
sistema un o col sistema 2 li
commettiamo in tutti e due modi
dipende ma non non voglio tanto
concentrarmi qua sull'errore quanto sul
concetto di libertà siamo più liberi
Quando utilizziamo il sistema uno o
quando utilizziamo il sistema 2 Eh il
sistema 1 è click e Run quindi vuol dire
che quando ho uno stimolo io do la
risposta e quindi se ho se è una
risposta che che ho sviluppato per mio
interesse Allora io sto perseguendo i
miei interessi e non sono libero ma in
qualche modo lo li sto perseguendo i
miei i miei obiettivi Ma noi Impariamo
anche perché siamo viviamo in una
comunità siamo condizionati da questa
comunità in modo consapevole o
inconsapevole quindi le nostre modalità
click and Run spesso non sono nostre ci
limitano nel nostra libertà di prendere
decisioni ma anche il sistema 2e
e non è così diciamo così propenso alla
libertà Perché Perché la libertà nel
quando il sistema 2 affronta le
decisioni in modo libero Ecco che è
soggetto alla paura la paura
dell'incertezza la paura di ciò che non
conosciamo la paura di non savere tutte
le informazioni la paura di non avere il
tempo per prendere le decisioni più
razionali Ecco che allora il sistema 2
diventa un sistema che si autolimita che
ci blocca che non ci fa decidere Oppure
che passa il pro la palla al sistema 1 e
quindi lascia il sistema un a lavorare
Ecco perché noi diciamo dobbiamo fare in
modo di entrare in un altro spazio se
vogliamo veramente darci questa
possibilità della libertà è ovvio che il
sistema 1 e il sistema 2 funzionano e
vanno benissimo nella maggior parte dei
dei casi però dobbiamo anche darci una
possibilità di indagare di esplorare di
attraversare quello che io chiamo il
pensiero di mezzo il pensiero 1 e mezzo
appunto che sta tra il sistema uno e il
sistema 2 ed è quello che noi chiamiamo
che che in generale viene chiamato il
processo cognitivo della creatività qui
vedete i due termini fondamentali che
spesso si utilizzano quando si parla di
psicologia cognitiva della creatività
cioè divergenza e convergenza la
divergenza il pensiero divergente è
l'input della creatività il pensiero
convergente è l'output della creatività
quindi nella prima parte io elaboro le
informazioni e trovo una serie enorme di
di di di opzioni e attraverso il la
convergenza io arrivo a definire
solamente un numero un piccolo numero di
opzioni potenzialmente arrivando alle
famose due alternative che dovrebbe
essere l'ottimo Per quanto riguarda il
processo decisionale in mezzo Però c'è
il pensiero di mezzo che è un mondo a
parte perché è è fatto sia di eh
processi analogici sia di processi
analitici ed è lì che avviene la sintesi
magica cioè quella quell' integrazione
particolare di informazioni di emozioni
di immagine di parole che ci permettono
veramente di elaborare in un modo che
non è attenzione sotto il controllo
pieno della
consapevolezza le le informazioni
attraverso una nuova organizzazione
corticale cioè quello che stiamo dicendo
non è solamente un processo metaforico
un percorso narrativo è qualcosa che ha
delle evidenze scientifiche alla base
cioè quando noi entriamo nel pensiero di
mezzo nelle esperienze senza nome
in Dove dove riusciamo a costruire i
cosiddetti Ponti metaforici tra concetti
che che tra loro altrimenti non
potrebbero comunicare qui abbiamo un
cervello che funziona in modo diverso
Cioè abbiamo un' iof frontalità e
un'attivazione invece di altre aree che
collegano i in modo diciamo così
particolare alcune strutture mediali del
nostro cervello è il cosiddetto default
Mode network quindi entriamo in una
modalità diversa di elaborazione delle
informazioni e qui ci rendiamo conto che
molte cose possono avvenire perché
perché in questo mondo di mezzo abbiamo
un processo particolare cioè la
sospensione della paura la paura di
lasciarci andare un pensiero
ampio noi tendenzialmente siamo portati
ad un pensiero verticale no immaginate
di voler sapere qualcosa di volerlo
conoscere di voler sempre andare in
profondità come dentro un tombino alla
ricerca sempre di nuovi particolari Ecco
questo è il pensiero verticale che a un
certo punto non ci può più dare
soddisfazione perché non riusciamo ad
aggiungere significato a quanto già
sappiamo il pensiero invece della
creatività è un pensiero che espande è
un pensiero laterale che in modo
rizomatico riesce a connettere varie
dimensioni della realtà ed è qui è
questo il vero segreto perché andando a
connettere in questo modo I pensieri e
anche le emozioni noi riusciamo a
sospendere quelli che sono gli effetti
emotiguy In qualche modo ci porta verso
l'incertezza verso la paura Qui invece è
come se ci aprissimo ad uno scenario
immaginat no anziché scendere verso il
basso saliamo una collina arriviamo alla
fine e vediamo uno scenario di fronte a
noi quello è la Terra di Mezzo Quello è
il pensiero di mezzo che ci permette di
fare delle grandi scoperte Io credo che
attraverso i processi creativi Noi siamo
in grado perché attenzione la creatività
non è un dono che hanno pochi È un
processo cognitivo che è suffici è
sufficiente attivare è quello che noi
chiamiamo lo Stato C on quindi
Creativity on Bisogna solo trovare il
trigger di ognuno noi crediamo che
attraverso la creatività No siamo in
grado di prendere decisioni migliori e
prendendo decisioni migliori sospendendo
l'attività automatica del sistema 1 e
quella invece diciamo
emotiguy qu donandoci una maggiore
Libertà Ma per fare questo dobbiamo
lavorare non solamente con gli individui
Ma dobbiamo lavorare a livello anche
sociale a livello sociale diceva e qui
prendo a prestito appunto le parole de
di di Silvano arieti il grande
psichiatra che diceva Dobbiamo creare
una società creativ ogen cioè che genera
in modo sistematico la creatività che
spinge ad ognuno ad avere Questi
strumenti della creatività e di dare
l'opportunità di utilizzare Questi
strumenti e come si fa adesso lo dico
molto velocemente qui ho cercato anche
di attualizzare Ovviamente questi questi
assiomi questi postulati uno dobbiamo
diffondere i mezzi della creatività e
dobbiamo renderli accessibili a tutti
ancora oggi i mezzi creativi i mezzi di
diffusione della creatività sono
veramente riservati a una piccola Elite
due dobbiamo aprire le culture Cosa vuol
dire una cultura deve avere una propria
identità Ma deve essere anche aperta
alle culture vicine in modo da inglobare
gli stimoli che da essi vengano e di
permettere quindi di essere cross
fertilizzata dagli stimoli culturali di
modo che io nel mio terreno con il mio
terroir particolare riesca a fare
germogliare frutti nuovi frutti che nel
mio terreno potranno nascere e in quello
del vicino non potranno nascere Ma che
allo stesso tempo avranno l'identità di
entrambe poi una società della cultura
ed una società in cui si sospende
l'essere e si spinge per il divenire Che
cosa significa e qui chiudo significa
che bisogna imparare a ritardare la
gratificazione cioè rallentare il nostro
modo di confrontarci con l'ambiente
rimanere sul presente proiettandosi in
un futuro che non ha un orizzonte
specifico e che quindi io posso guardare
senza ansia oggi Noi viviamo con l'ansia
del feedback del like della
gratificazione immediata e questo è è la
società del consumo Io aspetto di di
vedere il prossimo episodio perché sento
che quello mi gratifichi non mi ha
gratificato a sufficienza le prime 150
puntate ho bisogno della 151a e la
voglio subito non la voglio tra 6 mesi o
tra un anno altrimenti mi abbono ad
un'altra piattaforma Questa è la società
che noi non esistevano ai tempi di
arieti Questo è un libro degli anni 70
ma è questa è la società del divenire
del dell'essere che in qualche modo deve
essere rallentata per permettere invece
di apprezzare la gratificazione a lungo
termine e che in questo modo anche
Diminuendo i consumi diminuendo quindi
le decisioni e i comportamenti predatori
del della terra ovviamente ma anche
della società non solamente della terra
in quanto in quanto pianeta e
soprattutto rendendoci più liberi di
apprezzare noi stessi in modo che ognuno
di noi abbia la possibilità di vivere il
proprio presente ma anche quando lo
vuole di ricercare il proprio tempo
perduto
[Applauso]
Grazie